[Music]
this is the dream it's conflict and it's
compromise laliline leads to 2017 Oscar
nominations with 14 nods the film ties
with Titanic and All About Eve for the
most nominations in Oscar history it's
very very excited both emma stone and
ryan gosling scored solo noms for Best
Actress and Best Actor but they aren't
the only ones making history this is the
first time in Academy Award history that
a black actor is nominated in every
acting category Denzel Washington
maheshtala ali ruth negga Viola Davis
naomie harris and Octavia Spencer were
all recognized nine movies are nominated
for Best Picture moonlight lion
manchester-by-the-sea fences arrival
hell or high water hidden figures
hacksaw Ridge and lala land maybe I'm
not good enough yes you are maybe I'm
not like a pipe dream a big surprise
five-time nominee Amy Adams failed to
score nom for her work in a rival and
while it was a long shot Ryan Reynolds
did not get any love for Deadpool he
reacted to the snub on Twitter quote
regularly scheduled tickle fight at Camp
Deadpool is still on congrats to all the
nominees for these brilliant film check
out the full list of nominations at et
online com
[Music]
you